thank you for
talking to me about this wonderful show
um i'm curious
what your first reaction was when you
guys heard that the theme would be
oregon trail for the new season i think
we were both like
what's that um we
i'm not from america and it feels like
it's definitely something that
american kids in the 90s were very
familiar with through the video game
we were doing our research and then we
were like oh okay it's like a western
and it's
the frontier america i got it
um but then yeah we have to catch up on
all the like
dysentery references and
all all the classic oregon trail stuff
did either we get to play the game did
you
hunt it down at all no i haven't can you
still play it
i don't know i mean i know there's ways
to like go way back and play like old
games
some places online but i don't think
it's widely available
i know there's like a modern because you
know how like
your phone listens to you or something
so when the show was first happening
like i kept getting ads for some ios
game that was called like oregon trail
um that just looked insane um but no i
haven't
uh i haven't played the og uh it's not
very fun you just die over and over
again
so yeah yeah it seems like one of those
frustrating like old games where you're
like
it's just impossible to succeed
and it just keeps jamming up and you're
like gonna break whatever device you're
playing it on
well i was also curious that i mean i
know this season there was also a bit of
a showrunner change did anything feel
different with simon not
uh you know in that headshot runner
position this year
yeah it felt kind of exciting in a way
where dan mark who's worked on the other
two seasons
and robert worked on the second season
they had um as far as i knew like not
been in this position
a lot before so there was that sort of
giddy
energy of someone getting to do this job
for the first time like getting to call
these shots
and so there was a lot of like you know
um
like fun new ideas and things like that
that were really exciting but
they also captured i think simon's voice
really well but also made it a little
bit their own
um and so it was kind of it's always
exciting when there's
sort of new energy i think
well and it was also unique for a lot of
people i i
assume because i think it was for a lot
of people it was their first project
backed
after the pandemic what was it like to
be back on a set during that
you know bizarre we were like
it's we were shooting in um
on this ranch in california in kind of
like a big spike of covert in california
um so that was pretty
freaky and um but luckily we were
shooting
i mean completely outside luckily the
oregon trail is
we're outdoors and um can stay pretty
like distanced and stuff so i think we
felt
like it was the safest possible way to
to be working
right now um but
also very strange of course yeah it's
really like
i was personally just like so happy to
have like somewhere to go
like i'm losing my mind but so it was
really like it was really nice to be
with people again
but one of the joys of making especially
a show that's like a few months is
getting to know the crew
and it's always so awkward and hard with
this covet part of it all
because like every you don't even get to
really interact with people that much
but on this show they did something cool
where
everyone had a name card uh badge
that had their face on it a picture of
their face
so at least you could somewhat be like
oh i might
recognize this person if i ever saw them
at starbucks
after they shoot um so it made it a
little bit more human which i was like
yeah we should do that on everything um
but yeah
well i'm sure for both of you who are
probably itching to get back to work and
get back to acting and then i'm sure
it's just really strange where you
feel like no one wants to come near you
while you're on set
yeah yeah and it definitely started
where like
you know we as actors in the beginning
were like yeah you know even we'll keep
distance from each other but then we
were like a month or two and we're like
lunch in your trailer lunch and mine
you're just like
i guess if we're taking our masks off
and we're tested like at least can we
hang out with each other because we're
so starved for like connection
we started to play a fun game of guess
that mouse
where we kind of like yeah it's really
bizarre not seeing
someone's mouth and it's shocking every
time because we'll see them like take it
off at like the lunch tent
or something or having water in between
takes and it's like
yeah a complete shock every time it's
never the mouth you think it's gonna be
so um that that brought something fun
and new to that
was also curious that i mean obviously
each season is changing setting and
characters
how much input do you guys have in the
creation of the characters that you're
you're going to be playing in the
upcoming season
uh zero
you didn't get to pick out your cool
bounty hunter outfit no
i always feel like at least i'll speak
for myself i'm like find out right
before we're about to go table and i'm
like what
is happening yeah the second season i
got to go to the writer's room so that
so i did get to i guess do that once uh
and then this season they did invite us
to do that but it was on zoom and
i'm not trying to add more zoom time to
my
existence on this planet so i was like
i'll keep it as a surprise but um
but yeah we they always ask and then we
say
stuff and then sometimes it makes it in
but it's kind of like a roll of the dice
in a very fun way where i'm like
you're opening a present and you're like
what am i gonna get to do yeah
did you guys watch any i mean i've only
been able to see one episode but it's
clearly kind of playing on a bunch of
western tropes
did you guys watch any westerns in
preparation of of
doing the season i started watching
bonanza
with my mom because she grew up watching
that and she loves that
and yeah you know and i also it's like
i love the horses um and then i also
watched
searches um which i really
i really enjoy but then it also stresses
me out because then you see the horses
go down
like they'll be shooting and and then
i'm like this is actually
i just want the horses to be to be happy
and
free and galloping but um
i love westerns i feel like it's it it's
such a it's such a dream to like get to
actually be in that fantasy land
it's really it's such a fun genre i
can't stand westerns
[Laughter]
i find them so boring but i will say i
have a new respect for them now
because i'm like god this is hard like
it's making one thing that was
fun we our dp blake mcclure
who's incredible he shot it like it was
a western so we had these
really huge like lights that were
actually
fire i think it was really and
yeah like yeah on like a bright day he
would put a huge
sunlight in front of our faces so we
were like and we were squinting
and we like we kept being like that's
exactly my eye line like i can't
like hey like you know cleanings would
that's why he's squinting like
yeah you always just look like the sun
is in front of your face
that acting style is really informed by
how you can't
open your eyes and and see if that makes
sense
there did seem to be some bright
lighting on there um my final question
for you both
should there be a season four do you
have an ideal hopeful scenario or
setting that you would
get to tackle that one tackle on that
one
mine is dogs i just came up with this
this morning because i knew i'd be asked
just like
a season with dogs doesn't that sound
fun
we're dog walkers just go really like
micro
yeah well that gets very meta with like
daniel's dog walking
meeting oh right train wreck
that's kind of cool if we could kind of
expand on that meme
it's like the golden age of content
we're expanding on daniel and i mean
three years ago for ten episodes for us
i wanna go to space i wanna go to the
future i want
like aliens i want that
i'm into it uh well thank you guys both
so much
i love the show i think you guys are
both fantastic in it and i can't wait to
see the rest of the season
thank you